my
in Starfleet because he believed in it
I joined on a dare you joined to see if
you could live up to him
you spent all this time trying to be
your father not a wondering just what it
means to be you it isn't uncommon you
know it's easy to get lost and the
vastness of space
there's only your stuff your sheep your
crew you really want to head back out
there huh
what the hell is this
they're boarding us
bed and ship
my god
I know why you here why we are all here
our captain will conference mercy will
be the last thing on his mind I am
counting on it
fear of death is illogical
fear of death is what eats us alive
everyone who goes there he kills that's
your friends are there we kind of just
leave him behind
Unity's got your strength it's a
weakness I think your honor estimating
humanity hold on to something all right
we'll do it do it
pardon me you like sassy
you
hey youtubers is Charlie there's a new
Star Trek trailer I'm also going to be
talking about the new Star Trek TV
series which is a completely different
thing so let's talk about the movie
stuff first this trailer is definitely a
vast improvement from the last trailer
you get a little sense of the trek eNOS
of the movie there is a lot of trek in
there Simon Pegg was very upfront about
that so they just had this big Star Trek
fan event where they screened about ten
minutes of the movie and there was a lot
of really awesome classic Trek footage
that just didn't make it into this
version of the trailer so we see the
crew of the enterprise out on the
frontier there on the third year of
their five-year mission remember they
were teasing that in the last movie
Kirk is getting ready to celebrate his
birthday it's a little melancholy
because he's getting a year older and
it's the anniversary of his father's
death
remember his birthday is the day that
his father died so birthdays for this
version of Captain Kirk are very sad
occasions Idris Elba is the villain he's
going to be terrifying it'll be awesome
the makeup the costumes look a little
bit like the JEM Hadar of Deep Space
nine but this is a completely new
species and even though the trailer kind
of launches you into the action of them
versus the crew the enterprise the
footage that they should offer the fan
event gives you some better context for
where he's coming from
like he's not just some mysterious
villain that's trying to kill you for no
reason at all later in the trailer we
see them crash onto the planet on that
planet we find the ruins of an NX class
starship so if you're not really big on
Star Trek history one of the most
important things in the Federation is
the idea of the prime directive do not
brazenly screw with alien civilizations
that have never met with the Federation
before or haven't achieved warp
capability usually that is the benchmark
for the Federation talking to another
species like hey look you're part of
this larger galactic community they kind
of addressed that during star trek into
darkness where curtis completely screws
with his alien civilization they wind up
seeing the enterprise as they're
escaping the planet and at the end it
almost looks like they're going to start
worshipping them as some sort of God
like oh my god this is a complete
nightmare the prime directive so it's
not super clear yet but it seems like at
some point in history some part of the
Federation
messed with this alien culture something
terrible happened and that's why he
thinks of Kirk as an invading force this
is the frontier you don't belong here
what are you doing here so this kind of
this undercurrent
of foreign powers invading in a
territory where they don't necessarily
belong you can draw any number of
real-world parallels to that that you
want but I think one of the best things
about the movie that you don't
necessarily get from this trailer just
because the trailers marketing materials
is that life on the enterprise is very
exciting they have a very tight bond
the kirk/spock relationship is an entire
metaphor for the movie as it is for all
of Trek in general we make a good team
yes I do tend to agree so those are just
things that did make it into the trailer
that they were talking about at this fan
event they had the cast there and one of
the really cool things that actually got
me excited for future movies if they
decided to do them is that Chris Pine
was like I would love to play an evil
version of Kirk he's basically talking
about mirror universe Kirk they haven't
really done that in the movies yet but
starting to talk about the TV series now
so there's a new TV series they're going
to do Mirror Universe things so I'm
going to transition to that I'm going to
play this really quick teaser it's for
the TV series not for the movie so it's
completely different
CBS presents a new adventure
so just explain what's going on with the
TV series they talked a little bit about
doing Mirror Universe things Bryan
Fuller has creative control so I can't
wait to see what it looks like because
he makes the most amazing TV series they
haven't said anything about the crew
it's not going to be the enterprise
it'll be a different spaceship and it's
going to air on their new CBS streaming
service so if you have HBO now it's
going to be like their version of that
but they're gonna air the premiere on TV
so you'll be able to see that first
episode no matter what but other than to
say they're going to do some of the most
classic Trekkie things that you could
possibly think of in really crazy
amazing weird ways we really don't know
anything about the crew what kind of
starship they're going to be on so it'll
be a little while before they drop an
actual trailer but I do know that
they're going to be premiering Star Trek
into beyond the movie at Comic Con it's
going to be on outdoor iMac so it'll
actually be a really cool fan event they
have said that the TV series is supposed
to premiere in January 2017 after a big
50th anniversary event for the franchise
so they'll start filming later this year
so hopefully we'll actually see some
footage they'll start to announce cast
members castings things like that
they're all still figuring that stuff
out
so let me know in the comments what do
you think about the movie trailer and
what do you want them to do on the TV
series a lot of you have asked I am
totally planning on doing videos for
Star Trek whenever it comes the TV
series I have no idea what it's going to
look like so a lot of it'll just a pin
on when ends up happening when they end
up dropping like what day it is on so
we'll figure it out don't worry but the
other big news is I'm going to be doing
a flash trailer video later tonight so
be sure to subscribe to get that
there'll be all kinds of crazy stuff
going on next week where you guys wait
for that video to post you can click
here to learn all about Justice Society
in the arrow flash universe and you can
click here to get ready for Game of
Thrones this weekend thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
I'm
you